hi my name is jefferson white and i play
jimmy herdstrom on yellowstone
[Music]
you're alone jimmy
i'll take that as a yes
jefferson white first of all
congratulations you are a part of the
number one show on tv how does that feel
it feels incredible i feel incredibly
lucky uh and it's all
obviously you know i've loved the show
for years i've loved the show since we
started making it since the first time i
read the script so it's an incredible
gift to
to sort of feel that
for other people to sort of get a chance
to see it and to fall in love with it
the way that we have you know it's kind
of hard to describe with words how
uncomfortable i am right now what kind
of reaction do you get in your everyday
life
i live in brooklyn new york so out there
it's pretty mellow everybody's very cool
everybody's very distant which is a
bummer for me because i'm always walking
around trying to get recognized you know
i'm always like
making protracted eye contact with
people like do you want to talk to me
nobody wants to talk to me it's my first
date with the texans so i don't really
know the protocol
so brooklyn boy what
drew you to the project talk to us about
the casting process from the beginning
uh so i read the script in you know 2016
i think it was my agent sent me the
script and they originally had me
auditioning for casey for the role of
casey
which i read and i was i was so
immediately obsessed with the script and
the role casey that's an incredible part
but i also sort of recognize right away
that's not me you know that's
an ex-navy seal ultimate badass cowboy
so what i did was i loved the script so
much and i knew i wasn't quite right for
the part so i went through the script
looking for anything else that fit so i
immediately sort of connected with jimmy
that really felt kind of right
right down the middle for me you know
just a sort of guy
trying desperately to keep up a guy
who's in over his head sort of trying to
survive in a world that's that's very
new to him that really resonated with me
but i also
so i made a tape for jimmy without
anybody asking me to
uh which could have gone either way but
worked out pretty well were you
you were the yellowstone i thought the
yellowstone was gonna get me out of
trouble so let's dive into season four
of yellowstone when you read the script
and saw for the first time that jimmy
survived after being unresponsive on the
ground because i'm not gonna lie for a
second we thought we lost you yeah yeah
yeah what was your reaction well first
of all it was like yeah there's four
people who are in you know
dire dire straits here you've got kevin
costner american legend and then you've
got
kelly reilly who plays beth and you've
got luke grimes three duttons they're in
danger so if anybody's expendable let's
all be honest about who's expendable
it's me
so reading the end of that i was like oh
boy if anybody's going jimmy's going and
i you know i read that script
i know because it's the finale of season
three that i'm not going to read another
script for six months which means i
don't know if i'm gonna have a job or
not for six months so i'm just
frantically texting everybody and let's
be honest about who responds very few
people you know i'll end up texting
denim and being like denim have you
heard anything and he's like why would i
have heard anything
but when i found out i survived i was
incredibly grateful to keep
to you know keep doing the best job i've
ever had in my life you know what i mean
to get to keep working on the ranch and
keep working with those guys that's the
best job i've ever had in my life what
happened to him
it's not a list of things we need to
discuss so it really is top secret then
like you don't know how far in advance
the storyline goes for jimmy
i don't know anything and that's i think
appropriate for jimmy particularly yeah
for jimmy
[Music]
well i'm glad we're all glad that he
survived because there are so many more
stories to tell with jimmy i love when
you mention about casey you said you
know he's this ultimate badass cowboy
but look now at this full circle moment
at jimmy being an ultimate badass cowboy
jimmy's yeah jimmy's come a long way uh
he's still got a long way to go the more
i learn about this stuff the more i
realize how little i know you know and
it has a way of humbling you anytime i
start to get ahead of myself or start to
imagine that i've got it all under
control the horse has a way of humbling
you you know
now obviously jimmy is a fan favorite
and i feel like a lot of people would
even argue he's the heart of the show
why do you think it's so easy for people
to root for jimmy
that's very kind and i appreciate
people's response to jimmy so much i
think part of it is just that he's new
to this world too i think people really
connect to the show in part because it
has these huge sort of romantic sweeping
sort of idyllic
views it's this kind of epic world it's
this sort of you know the american west
we romanticize all the time there's this
sort of the legend of the american west
and i think people really connect to
that and then jimmy's so new to it it's
a world that jimmy
is uh just learning about and just sort
of trying to find his footing in so i
think in some ways he becomes a bit of a
audience stand-in you know for me that
that's been my experience with jimmy is
that i've been
learning about this world this culture
this community alongside him and that's
a way in which i've
connected to him from the beginning is
that we're both sort of outsiders
looking in
and outsiders desperately trying to fit
into this world so you'd say you're
pretty similar to your character than in
real life in a lot of ways just minus
the horses in brooklyn that part
exactly yeah in a lot of ways it both
largely in that we're both just
sort of uh learning and doing our best
to learn from everyone around us and
that's that's certainly been the case
for for jimmy from the beginning he's
new to this he's desperately watching
rip lloyd john dutton trying to pick up
everything he can and that's absolutely
the case for me on the show too you know
i
feel so lucky to be surrounded by such
brilliant actors who i've admired for so
long and in the same way that jimmy's
learning from those characters i'm you
know looking to cole hauser learning
from cole hauser learning from kelly
riley learning from kevin costner every
chance i get you know so the same way
that
jimmy looks up to these characters and
sort of aspires to earn their
you know respect i i feel exactly the
same way on set
action i know what you're thinking that
it's cruel what i'm doing sending you
away that it isn't fair
this isn't a punishment jimmy it's an
opportunity if you let it be kevin
costner to be able to now work alongside
him could you ever have imagined that
he's a myth himself you know he's a kind
of legend of american cinema western
cinema and i'm lucky in that jimmy is
awed by john dutton in the same way that
i'm awed by kevin costner so the real
gift to that is that i never have to
pretend
that i'm not you know
in awe of him
see you around jimmy
[Music]
see you around
what is your favorite part about playing
jimmy
i love honestly my favorite part of
working on the show and my favorite part
of playing jimmy is just getting to sort
of spend time in this world that i might
never have otherwise gotten to know you
know the western world
cowboying ranching
is a sort of lifetime pursuit it's a
kind of it's it's an entire sort of
world unto itself
and if not for yellowstone i might have
never had the opportunity to spend time
on horses to spend time in the rodeo
world in the ranching world and that
that's been an incredible gift so my
favorite part of working on the show is
the opportunity to learn about this
this world to learn about acting from
the brilliant actors on the show to
learn about writing and directing from
taylor who is obviously
a sort of myth unto himself taylor is i
think he's he's writing his own legend
right now you know he's an incredible
sort of uh
mythic figure in american television
right now about the horses
you like them it's kind of more like a
face into fear
so being being surrounded by
these brilliant
creatives and also being surrounded by
these brilliant cowboys and ranchers and
animal wranglers and stunt performers
that my favorite part of it is just
getting to learn from all these geniuses
how much training did it take for you to
pull off being such a believable cowboy
so i had never ridden a horse before
yellowstone i had never touched a horse
before yellowstone uh before we started
shooting the first season we had several
weeks to practice we are surrounded by
brilliant trainers brilliant horses
we've got it's a sort of best case
scenario if you're a [ __ ] who has never
touched a horse before which is uh what
i am
uh so we really were given every
opportunity to learn as much as we could
and still
and still fail constantly you know four
years later we're still very much
learning it's it's a lifelong pursuit
you know it's a shame that hurts the
most you know
did you have a fear of horses at all
going into it or were you pretty just
okay with that
you know actors we don't really get the
luxury of fear you know if they were
like hey your job is to ski down that
hill i would say you got it thank you so
much uh happy to be here you know we
don't have the luxury necessarily of
of that kind of choice um but like it's
also these animals and these trainers
are so brilliant that uh had i been
afraid i'm sure they could have
navigated that they really
they really are uh remarkable teachers
too so it was hard to be afraid in the
circumstances where i had the best
teachers with the best animals the best
resources available how am i gonna pay
for all this
well the hospital's pretty curious about
that themselves
jimmy he's he's no stranger to a
hospital now with these horses have you
had any real life injuries
knock on wood there's got to be some
wood around here um knock on wood i i've
been very lucky i've got some permanent
scars
just uh it's a little bit tmi on the
inside of my butt cheeks there's a kind
of
what do they call them rorschach inkblot
of scars wow um that will probably never
heal
other than that i've been very lucky
very sore very bruised very uh
very sort of beaten up but very lucky
we got to go back to the scars on the
booty because now it's like
it's
basically yours it's an evocative image
it's it's a version of the yellowstone
brand it's not on your chest
and now yellowstone is with you for the
rest of it and it is kind of a why shape
look at that you know
it's kind of a
permanent why
do you know if anyone has suffered
injuries that are similar to your scars
on your booty i think i was the newest
to riding on the whole show which is
lucky because jimmy's the newest to
riding on the whole show too so i think
i was the person who had the least
experience
and the least um
callous
but the real thing is that it's a little
bit of luck but it's also an incredible
amount of skill you know we're
surrounded by
horse trainers stunt performers
a safety team that keeps us incredibly
safe you know it's a tricky job their
job is to make it look as dangerous as
possible while being as safe as possible
and they always err on the side of
safety you know what i mean we don't
take risks they're really brilliant
at uh creating the feeling of frantic
action and frenetic
sort of chaotic movement while it's all
under control that said you can't really
like fake
bucking you can't really fake a [ __ ]
horse sequence so i have an incredibly
talented stunt performer who's been
playing jimmy as long as i have bobby
roberts and he's done all the bucking
sequences since then he does the stuff
he does the stuff they're not quite
ready to let me do yet
let's go fish jimmy when the cameras are
off in the bunk house what goes down
kind of the same thing it's not so
different when the cameras are rolling
we're always finding ways to compete
with each other we're very competitive
especially me denim richards and ian
bowen
who play colby and ryan we're always
finding ways to compete with each other
you could ask me on the date
i could i could do that so do it
you want to go on a date
yes
yeah
now jimmy went
0-60 with mia then he goes zero to sixty
not even sixty zero to a hundred jimmy
hits the gas very quickly when it comes
to women why do you think he falls so
fast is he a hopeless romantic deep down
inside i think there's very few people
in jimmy's life
who have ever taken any interest in him
looked him in the eyes seemed to show
any sort of genuine
care for him i think he's uh
kind of starved for attention and
starved for affection
let me buy you dinner
no i can't let you buy your dinner you
got a girlfriend
i i don't know
i think you had a very complicated uh to
say the least family life he's had a
very complicated to say the least
history prior to landing at the ranch
and then the ranch isn't exactly uh the
most nurturing environment it's a bit of
a trial by fire so i think for jimmy
anybody that pays attention to him and
sort of
sees him just a little bit the way he
wants to be seen i think he he falls
fast
[Music]
now with that being said who do you
think is better for jimmy mia or
emily
wow um he describes mia as having seen
him
as something
bigger than himself or an idea that he
like wanted to live up to but never
quite felt like he lived up to and it
feels like emily sees him to a certain
extent for who he really is you know
which is like
a hard-working guy who's out of his
depth and trying to keep up you know mia
saw jimmy to a certain extent as a rodeo
cowboy as a kind of rock star which
jimmy aspired to but i think could never
quite live up to and i think emily emily
sees jimmy for maybe who he really is
today you know which is a
a hard-working ranch hand just trying to
stay on the horse you know
in season four jimmy had that
opportunity to reach out to mia after
the breakup with a letter but he decides
against it why do you think that was you
never never text your ex you know what i
mean there's never snail mail them yeah
there's never a good reason to text your
ex uh because it's like what are you
looking for what what are you seeking
from that person by writing them and
where else can you find it you know
because if you write a letter that means
you're hoping to get a response what's
it gonna feel like if you don't get the
response you know what i mean like what
are when you reach out like that what
are you hoping to find
so i'm glad jimmy didn't uh you know
text his ex to a certain extent
looking back at season four
what was your favorite scene to film
season four was i mean an incredible
joy for me in general it was so many new
things for jimmy so many new sides to
jimmy the first three seasons jimmy
never quite gets his footing he's always
behind the eight ball a little he's
always scrambling to catch up which is
very fun to
as an actor as well it's fun as an actor
to be out of your depth but for the
first time in season four jimmy sort of
starts to come into himself
um and that's been an incredible gift to
sort of show these other sides of him
you know there's like jimmy the romantic
there's jimmy this sort of capable
you know it's maybe the first time we
see jimmy as capable of rising to what
he's asked to do
um
and so that was an incredible gift also
just getting to know the cowboys down at
the sixes seeing that space after
spending
you know four and a half years
up in montana the beautiful ranch up
there the yellowstone getting to know
that world it was an incredible journey
to get to see another side of the same
coin
down in texas in west texas i had never
been to texas in my life before we went
out to the sixes to shoot
and getting to know those cowboys
getting to know that lifestyle
was a was a tremendous pleasure in part
also because it represented so much
learning for me
are you ready
ready for one ready for work taylor
directed all those texas sequences you
know taylor was really
that that was his unit that he took down
to texas getting to learn from him at
every turn was an incredible incredible
gift and getting to learn from kat who
plays emily she's a brilliant actor
stepping into a show in its fourth
season stepping into this sort of
juggernaut show this huge world and
she's stepped into it so confidently
with so much
power and such a sort of
sense of herself
she kept herself
so
ably in an environment where it's easy
to get sort of thrown off your axis you
know yeah she's an amazing actor when we
first were introduced to jimmy you know
he's scruffy and you know he's got a lot
of facial hair now he's you know more
clean shaven and just looks a little bit
more put together is this
that next chapter of maturity for him
i hope so yeah i ended up you know that
beard that quote-unquote beard that i
had for four years is about the best
that i can do
you know i had to start growing that
thing
three months prior to shooting and just
walk around with this really patchy kind
of embarrassing nightmare on my face so
i'm grateful that jimmy is evolving in
that way um it's been a real yeah it's
also like
as different things are asked of jimmy
he evolves and his body evolves in
different ways rodeo cowboys have a very
specific kind of uh body that's that you
develop you know incredibly thick neck
just from getting bounced around on the
back of a bucking horse that's different
a little different than a ranch hand's
body that's a little different than uh
you know a meth head's body which is
where jimmy started out
you're a two-time loser jimmy
one more felony and they throw away the
keys
all right
i touch a lot of horses now i've often
i've gotten in trouble a few times on
the set for petting the horses too much
because you're not petting them is
supposed to be like a reward when they
do a good job and i just walk around
petting them all they all think they're
doing exactly they're doing a good job
just standing there i'm sending mixed
signals you know you got treats in your
pocket you got carrots you're just like
hey come on man please quit petting that
horse and now they're going to act up in
the scenes because they think they're
always here i'm undermining their years
of training by petting them they're
really cute oh my goodness but they're
also athletes we gotta talk about
obviously the spin-offs with yellowstone
now this has become a universe and you
are a part of this universe how does
that feel
um it's incredible as a huge fan of the
show and i've been a fan of the show
with all due respect to fans of the show
i've been a fan of the show longer
because i read the scripts
so i've been a fan of the show for you
know four and a half years now and so
when i heard about 1883
i i am so excited for 1883. the cast
they've put together so y'all just sit
and watch you look like he had it
figured
thanks for the help
the production design that like you know
we mythologize the american west and
yellowstone is a little bit about what
comes after you know yellowstone is
about this modern west the evolution of
this grand
tradition this grand legacy
so seeing sort of where it comes from
and the sort of seed of that west i'm so
excited and that cast is
truly bonkers billy bob thornton is one
of my sort of all-time idols there's
only one killer in fort worth and that's
me i'm so excited to see everybody's
work in that show tim mcgraw and faith
hill i was waiting for it i was like
incredible obviously it goes without
saying sam elliott a legend a legend an
incredible actor yeah so the pedigree of
those actors and then seeing taylor like
i'm also a huge fan of taylor sheridan's
work you james dutton yes sir
mind if we speak whatever you're selling
i ain't buying to see him do a period
piece like this as far as i know it's
the first sort of foray of his into uh
period you know into into the past and
he has such an incredible sort of
powerful singular vision i am so excited
to see that play out in the west
good luck jimmy like said luck has
nothing to do with it no i said luck has
nothing to do with horse showing for
this you're gonna need all the luck you
can get see you around
and obviously also we have the sixes and
jimmy helped introduce the sixes to
the audience what are you most excited
for fans to see more of at the ranch i
think you know
what's incredible about the six is is
it's a real ranch you know the sixes is
uh one of the oldest ranches in texas
one of the oldest ranches in the country
one of the sort of largest
functioning
cattle ranches and you know horse
training and breeding facilities in the
country and so i think you know
i'm really excited for people to see the
kind of real gritty
not glamorous world
of real life cattle ranching you know
now
in in modern times what do you think
should be a part of
the sixes spin-off anytime i think i
know what should happen next
something completely different happens
and it's way better than my idea taylor
has only ever surprised us
thrown us curveballs that we never would
have expected and that is the greatest
gift you know you don't want to put
you don't want to put a dumb ass like me
in charge of decisions like that all i
can really do is try to hold on to the
horse you know no no no no
you gotta give yourself more credit you
are doing an amazing job
i mean
that's very kind i feel incredibly lucky
to be just holding on you know just
holding on sort of flopping around and i
haven't fallen off yet yet i've fallen
off a few times but so far i've gotten
back up
[Music]